stolen tech think I know what look we
can use it to it stop cicada gentlemen
welcome to the market let's make a deal
I'm making the deal with the depth
tonight you're in for gold face
why why
lie to me
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of new flash footage to break down
there's some leftover red death flash
questions from last week's episode that
all addressed and some future teasers
for a crisis on Infinite Earths and
what's going on with cicada in the
future and if you're a really big comic
book fan they just brought god speed
back as part of this long gestating plot
and a really super deep cut flash
villain from a long long time ago if
you're big Mark Waid flash fan so of
course we'll do a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite flash villain on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this so
first big thing about the episode
they're basically doing the plot from
Mission Impossible fallout where Tom
Cruise had to pretend like he was a
villain and perform a heist with the
white widows crew so that he could get
what he needed but they did this really
weird montage where Ethan Hunt kills
someone like he's imagining himself on
this heist and is like no no no I can't
kill anybody so he has to think of a way
to perform the heist but make things go
off the rails enough so that he can call
an audible and won't have to kill anyone
because Ethan Hunt Tom Cruise's
character is supposed to be a hero he
won't kill innocent people so a lot of
the tension is as in how things go off
the rails and how he saves the situation
without totally going to the dark side
and killing somebody that's innocent so
very clearly they're setting the flash
up for the exact same twist Barry is
wearing what looks like a metahuman
power dampener so maybe he can't use his
flash powers because they're trying to
infiltrate this crime organization led
by a Green Lantern villain named gold
face so he's forced to perform a heist
with that crew and is forced with the
decision whether or not he's actually
gonna kill innocent people but because
it seems like he doesn't have his powers
he has to think of a Tom Cruise mission
impossible' way of making things go off
the rails so that he can call an audible
and save the situation if you haven't
seen it yet just go watch Mission
Impossible fallout before this episode
happens and you'll understand totally
what that scene is all about
they're also introducing one of
Sherlock's wives and it's gonna be the
woman from the father of the bride
movies you probably recognize her from a
lot of other stuff but if you remember
the Council of Welles from previous
seasons where you have a bunch of
different versions of Harrison wells
they said that they would be doing the
same thing for Sherlock's storyline but
with his wives
we'll be like the council of Sherlock's
wives with a bunch of different versions
of them eventually I'll talk about all
the godspeed stuff in a second - but
addressing some of the biggest red death
and cicada questions from my last
episode 12 video that you guys had yes I
do believe based on this scene that it's
Grace who takes the mantle of cicada in
the future which is why he seems like
he's immortal because people don't know
that it's secretly her underneath the
costume and that's why it seems like
he's killed so many people because of
that big teaser - killed more people
than zoom killed more people than the
Red Death so grace is still the key to
the season but based on Barry's teaser
at the end of the episode he wants to
cure cicada of his affliction of his
metahuman powers so maybe that will save
him and then that will cause grace to
chill out because right now it almost
seems like she's more off the rails than
the actual cicada and if you look at
some of his performances he is just so
over the top so maybe they've been doing
that on purpose to mislead you making
you think that he's supposed to be the
villain when really it's actually what's
going on with grace that becomes the
bigger problem in the future that
they're all trying to avoid as for
future red death on the TV show yes
there are a number of ways they could
substitute Batman merging with the
version of Barry Allen to become TV show
red death but here's the thing a lot of
you were like what about Batwoman or
Oliver Queen substituting for the Bruce
Wayne Batman fusion with Barry Allen
because in the comics Red Death is sort
of like a dragon ball fusion of a couple
different characters in the comics it's
a dark universe version of Bruce Wayne
that forces a fusion with his universes
version of Barry Allen it's a little bit
like firestorm where you have someone in
the driver's seat but you also have
someone's consciousness trapped in there
with you
so Bruce Wayne is in the driver's seat
and you have Barry Allen's consciousness
trapped in there with him so people are
just trying to think of alternate
universe evil versions of our good
characters that could fuse with a Barry
Allen and become the Red Death but the
big problem with that is is that I don't
think they say like Stephen Amell even
though like that would be pretty cool to
see an evil version of Stephen Amell
looking like the Red Death I don't think
that he's gonna pull double-time and be
a villain on the flash all season long
while he's also doing arrow stuff we
don't know how long arrow is gonna go
who knows how many more seasons they're
gonna get but even if they get cancelled
I don't think that Stephen Amell would
more than like a couple episodes of the
flash as a guest star like he's actually
winding down in the air overs so
eventually when arrow does go off the
air I think that he only comes back for
a couple episodes a year particularly
big crossover stuff so when you're
thinking about TV show red death what
they'll probably do is they'll probably
find a version of that character that
can be a villain on the flash all season
long and still be really cool so that's
probably why it won't be Oliver Queen's
Stephen Amell or Batwoman because that
one will be busy on her TV show too so
when you're thinking about who TV show
red death could be just in terms of
actors just remember to be practical
about it but aside from godspeed another
really cool flash twist villain they
could do would be a cobalt blue which is
also kind of an evil version of Barry
it's like a Thawne raised twin of Barry
Allen from the Mark Waid comics which it
seems like they may be bringing back in
the comics which I'll explain in a
second but use that to imagine that that
would also probably be a different twist
too because for a long time in the early
seasons people were like maybe Eddie
could come back and he could be a
version of cobalt blue like that would
be different from the comics but it
wouldn't have to be an evil version of
Barry because we've kind of already done
that in sabot R the other thing that's a
little bit different about cobalt blue
is that it's actually a cobalt blue
family that extends across time the same
way the flash family extends across time
so like Barry Allen has twins they
become speedsters those children have
their own children who also become
speedsters one is Bart Allen and on the
other side of the family it's excess
obviously they're using excess as Noor
Allen this season so they're probably
not gonna do the geniag Knotts version
of excess but is the same thing for the
cobalt blues so they did that during the
Mark Waid era it was a long time ago
it's a super deep cut and it seems like
they're slowly coming back in the
rebirth era comics right now but if
you're a big comic book godspeed fan
they actually just brought him back as
part of this long gestating plot that
goes back to last year so Barry Allen
broke him out of prison last year in
order to help them defeat Grodd who was
trying to steal the Speed Force from
everyone when they defeated him God
speed disappeared but there was a
post-credits scene where you see him
talking to a shadowy figure offering him
a chance to fix all of his problems now
you finally find out
who he was talking to and it seems like
it is a super deep cut flash villain
during the flash annual there's this big
plot where he's betraying all the flash
members and messing with people like
Mina who is their sort of female version
of the reverse-flash with the negative
Speed Force Bart Allen has come back
from the Speed Force but he hasn't met
up with most of the flash family yet
because they're still kind of dealing
with the death of ginger Wally West as
part of the heroes in crisis storyline
that's going out that's sort of like the
overarching big DC event right now it
even though godspeed is kind of upset
about having to betray the flash because
they are still friends godspeed has kind
of become the Red Hood of the flash
family like the person who's kind of a
villain but he's kind of good at the
same time but it seems like he is now
serving a new master whose crackling was
Speed Force energy in all of his speech
bubbles have a blue ring around them he
claims that he's going to get back at
the flash for what he did to his family
so it sounds like they're implying that
he's cobalt blue and he's going to fix
the cobalt blue family which like I said
is a big deep cut for the Mark Waid
comics it got really complicated with
the cobalt blues and the lineage they
got into all these crazy family trees
it's basically a thawne version of the
flash family but cobalt blue himself the
original one looks like Barry Allen
because they're twins so you have a
Barry looking villain and it seems like
that's gonna be their big storyline this
year suppose all your reactions in the
comments below
congratulations Dirk Jensen you're the
giveaway winner from my last big flash
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for my flash season 5 episode
12 red death video with all those Easter
eggs and click here for that birds of
prey trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]